- But you left college
to make YouTube videos,
so exactly how excited were
your parents about this?
- They were, they were the ones
that actually encouraged me
to, like, pursue my dreams
and move out to L.A., so--
- Whoa.
- I know, right?
I had the blessing of a brown parent,
you know that don't happen every day, no.
(audience clapping)
- Blessing of a brown--
- I did, I did.
So, my dad and my mom actually
met in theater class in college
and my dad was told he would only be,
like, stereotype-cast as a brown man.
And so, now here I am, bein' a brown girl
doin' all the things--
- Oh, that's why.
- I'm doin' it for him.
- That's why you're for you, yes.
- I'm so proud to represent.
- That's so cool and
that's where you must get
your talent from, that
both of them are like, wow.
- Yeah, that's what they like to say.
My sister says I stole her personality--
- (laughs) My sister and I are identical,
so I didn't steal anything, Lisa.
So, who's like your favorite person
you've ever had on your YouTube channel?
- Um, lucky enough, I had Barack Obama,
President Barack Obama,
on my YouTube channel.
- Wow.
- I know.
He's big into the YouTube.
- That's amazing.
- Yeah, it was--
- What was that like?
Were you nervous?
- Oh, so nervous.
The man walked into the
room, he smelled like
all types of pumpkin spice
fall candles, like, he,
(laughing)
every candle, every
dryer sheet known to man,
that's what he smells like.
- Oh my gosh.
- Did he play himself?
- He played himself.
- 'Cause I was gonna say,
I would love to see him
playing something else.
- He played the President and
he did the role really well.
- Yes, imagine that.
- Yeah, yeah. (laughs)
(audience clapping)
- Try clapping now.
- Yes, I'm clapping now.